[Musique]
par qui que vous importe que mon nom
apparaisse dans la liste de vos
conquêtes j'ai bon espoir
son orgueil est telle qu'il n'ose
rentrer à paris sans avoir vaincu sa
proie
dois je comprendre que vous vous êtes
abandonné aux marques et toutes les
passions ne se ressemblent pas la nôtre
est un temps sans être excessive une
sentiments sont aussi plein de tendresse
et d'horizon
[Musique]
mais si possible de connaître ses
pensées qui m'éloigne de vous j'ai peur
quatre nouveaux fachos tenté me fâche
[Musique]
vous vous souvenez de madame de
jonquière ce n'est pas qu'ils ne soient
belles comme un ange que le net de la
finesse de la grâce mais elle n'a aucun
esprit de libertinage
pourquoi le marquis s'attacherait t-il à
cette fille alors qu'ils ne s'attachent
à aucune autre parce que le martineau
résiste pas ceux qui lui résistent mal à
mon avis - chéri ce qu'elle est les
combats sur moi je voulais avoir l état
de votre coeur il faut que j'essaie de
finale jean pérès
je vous en supplie madame il sacrifie la
moitié de sa fortune espace assez pour
moi le compte n'y est pas je crains
cependant que votre entreprise soit
excessive à mon entreprise est en-deça
de ma douleur et du coup que le marquis
ma portée je me fais dix hommes à leurs
trousses nous y retrouver je reçois
leurs portes je suis ce que je ferai
vous avez tout à cannes de l'état tué
leur permettez que je suis
si aucune âme juste ne tente de corriger
les hommes qui meurent espérer de
meilleures sociétés
[Musique]